ministers agreed that we have to
increase our attention to European
scallops when it comes to access to
finance at different stages on their
development it is evident that
traditional loans from banks are not
sufficient and Minister showcased
examples of new innovative financial
products business angels venture capital
or crowd funding offer additional
opportunities for funding a national
level but we need to think out of the
box the European steel industry is
confronted with challenges which have
put in the inner it under a huge
pressure there are several reasons for
that but the most important is certainly
the search in steel imports from China
this cause for adjustment adjustments
but China cannot solve its problem of
still over capacity on the back of the
European steel industry real problem are
the problems in Europe starts when
trying to grow to the company going from
the startups to the scale with what we
call scallops we agreed that we need
really urgent action in Europe on this
on different levels of course national
european regional and we need to look at
it as it added very compressively from
the angle of access to finances with
this which is extremely important but
it's not not only not the only one
problems but also in terms of public
procurement for example taxation
intellectual property evaluation much
making between the companies and is
scallops as as you know we adopted the
communication on on European agenda for
the collaborative economy what I want to
underline again is that the Commission
does not does not favor one business
model over another it is for consumers
not regulators to choose which services
and with business models they prefer and
our main job now is to ensure that
existing kilo is consistently applied
across the EU single market let me
mention also a very shortly signature
signature or completing signature of the
joint disease initiative on
standardization this is important for
industry this is important for our
companies especially as a nice but not
only thanks to the efforts of slovak
presidency we completed the process and
we can really preserve the situation
when we are and will be europe will be
the half of the standards globally